[Music]
in the last say five years you can pick
the time frame but recent history what
new belief behavior or habit has most
improved your life
i think the biggest one of all and this
was really
big during
writing the book which was this you know
enormous challenge it was like my main
focus for two years over the course of
the pandemic
was evening check-ins with
an employee of mine who also functioned
a bit like a productivity coach so every
evening i would uh set deadlines for the
next day both input and output so input
would be how many hours of tracked
lighting i would do
where going to the bathroom did not
count
a really big day would be six hours
sometimes very occasionally i'd kind of
get more than that
and also output goals as well so i'd say
i will have drafted this section or
these sections or i will have done such
and such
i would also normally make some other
commitments as well such as you know how
much time do i spend looking at reddit
on my phone
how much caffeine am i allowed to drink
do i exercise things like this
and laura
um
do it is wonderful and the nicest person
ever and
she just never beat me up about this
but i would beat myself up but it would
make me it was incredibly effective at
making sure i was just like actually
doing things because i like many others
find writing it's like hard it's like
hard to get motivated it's hard to keep
going
and
sometimes i don't know i'd have gotten
drunk the night before let's say and it
was a sunday and normally you just it
would be a write-off for the whole day i
think like oh no it should be so
embarrassing at 7pm to have to tell
laura like yeah i didn't do any work
because i got smashed
and so instead i would feel hungover and
i would just keep typing away
and that was just huge i mean i think it
increased my productivity
i don't know it feels like 20 or 25 or
something just from these like 10-minute
check-ins every day
so these were 10-minute check-ins seven
days a week what was the cadence i was
working six days a week so
but yeah if she was doing something else
at the weekend we wouldn't check in
right so the format would be
walk me through ten minutes would be the
first five minutes
here's how i measure it up to what i
committed and here's what i'm doing next
exactly so it would be a view of the day
so yeah did i hit my input goal my
output goal how much caffeine did i
think did i exercise and then also like
was i getting any migraines or back pain
which are two kind of ongoing issues for
my productivity
next would be a discussion of what i
would try to do the following day
and interestingly you might think of a
productivity coach as someone who's like
you know really putting your like nose
to the grindstone
whereas with laura that's kind of the
opposite because my problem is that i
beat myself up too much
so she's like luring e.t out of the
closet with the reese's pieces exactly
candy
yeah so i would be like oh i got so
little done today so i'm gonna have to
just have a 12-hour day tomorrow or
something or like i'll work through the
night or something like that and she's
like that doesn't make any sense like
you know we've tracked this before and
when you try and do this maybe you get
like an hour of extra work where you
feel horrible for days afterwards
and
so she would be very good at like
countering
[ __ ] that my brain would be
saying basically
so couple things caffeine
what were your parameters on caffeine
like what were the
limitations or minimums i don't know how
you said it on caffeine and then how did
you choose
this
employee specifically for this
and why
so caffeine i mean i think a big thing
is just if i drink too much i'm likely
to get a migraine
so i set my limit at three espressos
worth so about 180 milligrams of
caffeine and i'm very sensitive so it's
like 180 is legitimate for a sensitive
person exactly so that's like the max
that i do whereas double expresso was
fine
but then it's like shading in between
i'll be like really cautious about and
then how did i choose this person i
think it's like a very subtle thing
the kind of the poor or
personal fit you have with someone who
can be a good coach
where
she kind of knew me well enough that she
knew the ways to like push me around and
was like
yeah kind of the combination of like
maybe i call it friendly pushiness or
something was
is like perfect
you know it could be very easy to go
along on either side of that line
all right sounds like i need an evening
check-in all right
who's my who is my victim going to be
all right maybe we can spy it
will
i know i know i know it's i know it's
four in the morning but i had to call
you for my evening check-in
you